you did a video for people magazine yes
speaking for their uh funny is the new
sexy yes
issue funny yes i'm sorry you didn't
make it
how do you know i'm not in the just
plain sexy part exactly yeah i was gonna
say he's just sexy yeah i wasn't like
funny sexy it was just like that guy's a
hunk of pure sex yeah
dripping
look at that
incredible
that i'm getting all these awards we
were just talking about the people
magazine sexist man alive issue yeah and
i'm on the cover and then you're in it
and as some kind of don't laugh at that
it's plausible it's like 11
plausible you're in the um no not at all
you were in the funny and new sexy
uh yes funny is the new sexy use the
title because uh uh that i couldn't make
it as we were talking about as the
regular so uh and if you're that they
make you do a video they make you uh
sing for your supper so uh they they had
us do a hilarious sexy video um and they
said do a do a mundane activity and make
it sexy uh and so i tried uh
masturbating with clown gloves and uh
it's not easy yeah i went to the
emergency room yeah it was awful i
burned myself uh
started a fire uh so i got the uh
community cast members uh together too
yes thank you four people um and then
who joined in uh to i said i'm just
gonna make coffee i make i do make
coffee for the cast each morning and uh
so i i walked into my trailer and said
well this is what i do it's so
incredibly sexy but while the camera was
pointed away the all the male cast
members snuck into my trailer shirtless
and um
we proceeded to have a very uh
homoerotic cup of coffee i think we we
have this uh clip this is you with the
uh cast members from community let's
take a look
strong and black clothes
honey that you say steamy how was the ab
workout today ken oh it was
good good good okay it's paying off and
now the pants all right all right
[Music]
everybody
i'm still
ken zhong is in such good shape
oh my gosh she's amazing uh yeah donald
glover said if you look at ken jong
naked he looks like a melting alien
wow that's nice fish swimming towards
you that's nice